E aí
[Música]
o Olá a todos antes de começarmos
gostaríamos de agradecer imenso o
convite para estarmos aqui hoje a atuar
E sendo que o tema deste evento Então e
quietação a trazemos quatro músicas que
achamos que são as representam melhor
esse sentimento Vamos começar com a
clipe dos Radiohead
a new rivo fora eu te Sky que é
Ah e eu esqueci meu pai eu sou Dayco
sério não tiro fogo
a e na ixodes Peu show e absorveu
Special a
a moto G8 E aí ó
E aí don't care if I
E aí ou não
E aí
[Música]
E aí agora final antes não espera aí
E aí
não achou o
e a mão o arranjo o rei D
E aí
e além da hora hein Gay
[Música]
E aí
o Shih Tzu
oi Brenda mêncio rap do
Olá eu sou verbos show e negociação
oi oi
Oi Pera aí ó
e vamos agora então passar para um
original nosso chamado histórias para
contar o tema desta música surgiu numa
conversa de café há cerca de dois anos
atrás Enquanto estávamos a falar sobre
vários problemas que estavam existir no
mundo a nosso à nossa volta e esperemos
que gostem portanto Bora lá
E aí
a todos ficam indiferentes tudo cara
esquecimento menos em mim o Tutú que não
é inocente e tudo aquilo que sonhava ter
um fim eu era já feliz agora sumário
cicatriz não faço não digo não penso
tira as mãos em cima de mim em fazer
estragada não quero ser mais eu
Olá eu sou a Maria João não tem tantas
mortas todas em vão eu disse para ser
humano perdeu a razão a tua missão olha
para omundo estranho isso não sou de
ninguém já te disse para eu disse para
[Música]
mexer onde não há nada além da verdade
foi-nos tirado Esperança Rua retirada
não fazem nada quando é que isto acaba
Enquanto a cor da pele for mais
importante que o brilho dos meus olhos
continuaremos Mário a
é que o meu nome é Pedro quando é que
alguém se vai cortar eu disse para
entanto as bordas todas em vão eu disse
para grita em silêncio na multidão ser
humano perdeu a razão for para ser assim
uma visão olha para omundo estranho isso
não sou de ninguém já te disse para Lara
[Música]
[Aplausos]
o ser humano perdeu a razão aproxima sua
missão olha para Muniz tudo isso não sou
de ninguém para pois não faz mais sentir
E aí
mas eu não desisto a minha vida traga
recuperar quando é que isto vai acabar e
eu disse para parar não
e a o ser humano perdeu a razão A Fuga
será sua atenção olha para omundo
estranho isso não sou ninguém já te
disse para você para e olha para um
instrumento não sou de ninguém já te
disse para eu disse para eu te disse
para mim
e o próximo tema vai ser do cantor e
compositor Bob Dylan e aproveita então
para dizer que se quiserem podem ouvir a
nossa versão de sistema no Spotify em
várias plataformas digitais e podem
também seguir o nosso trabalho Facebook
ou no nosso Instagram ti por tudo.
Oficial a
E aí
[Música]
a lei no YouTube oscila tem um
e esse Roll vai na fé
E aí
é para me fala
Oi Vânia luz ter cross-play cantor look
acho lindo a mão do táxi aéreo na eu sei
[Música]
sei lá
eu sou
o celular
o menino e o sincorá maneira Ai que Neve
te foi a direi willzinho cale não a
maneira que um dia remou aos teus só
tenho 16 aí quem curtiu se sou ai baby
[Música]
baby
eu sou alto senha pelo é a fera para
toma ai vai voar e
e esse Donald's
e vai nanar
e vamos então agora passar para a nossa
última música Espero que tenham um outro
estado de não estarem aqui acompanhar
foi um prazer enorme estar aqui
Aproveite mais uma vez para agradecer o
nosso convite e empréstimos Espero que
seja possível estarmos todos juntos
novamente com antigamente não é verdade
muito obrigada
E aí
E ai mexer o é quentíssima e o make me
true bem difícil de wi-fi
o Santos em sonho britannia Janeiro e
Oi gente
e se está pode pronto te conhecer tá
[Música]
E aí
é né tirar e me moto Z no ai ai senhor
eu não quero ai meu coração por isso é
é só eu tava na cego de baixo depois
either aula então é
[Música]
bom então de chorar e nem por isso ai ai
Cirilo e não quero ver aula na colchão
favor isso não é
[Música]
E aí
E ai ai curte solar foi escrito
É sério sou e não you do
E aí
um animal Ai sim sorrir se mais sou fica
ligado à
[Aplausos]